حتى يتسنى لنا حمايه ذلك المجمع في الايام
والاسابيع القادمه
ونعتزم ان نستمر في هذه العمليه ولا اعلم
بماده تعنيه بالقول عن الخسائر التي تعرضت
له السفاره لكن كما تعلمون ان كافه
العمليات
الدبلوماسيه في السودان قد تم
توقفها
واجلائي كافه طواقم السفاره هذا الامر
يحدث بين فتره واخرى اذا نظرتم الى الامر
على مر سنوات تجدون ان هناك خروجا لبعض
الطواقم الدبلوماسيه من بعض السفارات هذه
هي طبيعه العمل
وخاصه في ظل انتشار 270 دبلوماسي في كافه
انحاء العالم اذا كانت الظروف غير مئاتيه
للاستمرار في العمليات الدبلوماسيه في
منطقه ما لكن هدفنا كما قلت هو ان نستمر
في العمليات في الخرطوم بمجرد قدرتنا على
القيام بذلك
كما تعلمون عندما تتعلق الامور بمسائل
التاشيرات الخاصه بالروس فهذه فهذا فهذه
المساله تخص بالجهه المعنيه بتلقي طلبات
التاشيره الخاصه بالدبلوماسيين الروس
في سياق الحديث عن خطه الطوارئ المتعلقه
بالسودان هل تنظرون في مساله نشر قوات حفظ
سلام لا توجد لدينا اي مرحله اي خطط لنشر
خطط لنشر قوه حفظ سلام في السودان ليس في
الفتره الحاليه لا نتوقع انها سوف تكون
ايضا في الفتره القريبه
هل لديكم اي خطط طارئه فضلا عن اجلاء
طواقم
الطواقم الدبلوماسيه من السفاره
هل لك ان تشرح لنا ما هي خطه الطوارئ تلك
لن اتكهن بالاشياء التي لم تحدث بعد لكن
عندما يتعلق الامر بقدرتنا على الاستجابه
والردف واذا ما شعرنا بانه كان هذا امرا
لازما من اجل حمايه موظفينا واذا ما كان
هناك اي تهديد نتعرض لها في الولايات
المتحده تمتلك القدرات للرد على ذلك لكن
من منظورنا في الفتره الحاليه نعتقد بان
المسار الحالي الذي نشده الا وهو ان نسح
ان نسهل
عمل الاجلاء هو الطريق الامثل للمضي قدما
وطالما ان اهدافنا لم تتعرض لاي تهديد
هناك
ترون اعدادا متزايده من الامريكيين الذين
يصلون الى بورسودان وهذا ما يدفع الى
الحيطه والحذر لعدم توجه اي مواطنين
امريكيين الى اماكن خطا خطره هناك هل هناك
اي خطط بالنسبه للسفر هناك وتحضيرات هناك
هناك مخاطر عند تحليق طائرات الهليكوبتر
في تلك المنطقه نحن لا نتحدث عن اي خيارات
امنه لكن من واجبنا نبلغ الامريكيين بان
هناك عمليات اقتتال تدور في تلك البلاد
وسواء مكان السفر عبر عبر الجو او عبر
البر كلها سوف تكون مصحوبه بالمخاطر اننا
نقوم بحسابك المخاطر بصوره دقيقه
ومن خلال عمليات حسابنا للمخاطر كنا نخبره
مواطنين بعدم السفر الى السودان لكننا
نقول في ذات الوقت بان بالنسبه لهؤلاء
الامريكيين المه في الانضمام لبعض القوافل
فكنا نقدم ما المعلومات حول كيفيه قيامهم
بذلك ونحن نقدم الان بعض
الدرجات المتزايده من الرقابه حول تحركهم
وراينا امريكيين بين في عداد تلك القوافل
وسوف نكون واضحين مع الامريكيين حول
المخاطر وحول الخيارات المتوفره لهم وسوف
نستمر في
اتصالا لاسيق مع هؤلاء الامريكيين عبر
الهاتف ووزاره الخارجيه تقوم بهذا الامر
بصوره يوميه في بعض الحالات
سوف نكون حاضرين لاي امريكي في السودان
يبحث عن دعم وتوجيهات من الولايات المتحده
هل لديكم اي تحديث حول مساله وقف اطلاق
النار واذا ما كان للولايات المتحده اي
دورا لتلعبه بين الاطراف المتقاتله وكيف
يمكن
للول ان تلعب دورا مهما في هذا الامر
البيت الابيض كان قد اجرى محادثات متعدده
وكذلك الامر بالنسبه لوزاره الخارجيه مع
سفيرنا الموجود على الارض من خلال اتصالات
هاتفيه متعدده
وكذلك بعد خروجه من البلاد لن اتكهن حول
ما قد يحدث لان الامور
ومتغيره ولكن
نامل ان يتم التوصل الى وقف اطلاق النار
الذي كان قد تم طرحه خلال فتره عيد الاضحى
لكنه لم يصمد
يبدو بان ان الاطراف المتحاربه خرق تلك
الخدمه تلك الخدمه وسوف نستمر بالعمل مع
شركائنا لدفع الطرفين المتقاتلين من اجل
تخفيض اعمال العنف وتوصل الى وقف اطلاق
اطلاق نار دائم لا استطيع ان اعطيكم
تنبؤات حول متى سوف يتم الوصول الى ذلك
لكننا نرى ان هناك امكانيه بمجرد
ممارسه وتطبيق كافه الادوات المتوفره
لدينا لتحقيق هذا الغرب
يتعلق بكوريا الجنوبيه وحزمه المساعدات
والتمارين العسكريه
الرئيسان الامريكي ورئيسي كوريا الجنوبيه
كان قد تطرقا الى مساله الردع المشترك
وخاصه من المخاطر
النابعه من الصين وانا سوف
القدر كان هذا مؤتمر صحفي لجيك سونيفين
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات